[Musique]
les parents des spurs nous révèle aussi
le rôle très troublant d'un partenaire
d'affaires de glencore glen corse est
une immense multinationales que des
filiales ici au canada et vous allez
voir comment les grosses entreprises
peuvent profiter des paradis fiscaux
pour faire des transactions
controversées
[Musique]
kl encore plus de cent cinquante mille
employés et sous traitants dans plus de
50 pays
des revenus qui se comptent par dizaines
de milliards dans le pétrole les mines
et même l'agriculture
ces activités sont aussi présentes d'un
bout à l'autre du canada avec des
terminaux à grains dans l'ouest et à
montréal sans oublier les produits
miniers de glencore en ontario au québec
jusqu'à la mine raglan au nunavik à tous
à son corps a eu l'honneur notre enquête
canadienne commence en république
démocratique du congo
quand on y retrouve notre collègue
français édouard perrin sur la trace des
activités minières de glencore rabat
parmi les multiples filiale de glencore
katanga mining limited retient notre
attention
elle possède une vaste mine de cuivre et
de cobalt ici dans la province du
katanga
mais entre la province du katanga est la
maison-mère de glencore en suisse le
canada entre en scène
parce que voyez-vous le siège social de
katanga mining depuis 2011
et ici à whitehorse au yukon à plus de
dix mille kilomètres de l'afrique
ça démontre que sur papier on peut
prétendre à peu près n'importe quoi les
actions de katanga mining sont
transigées à la bourse de toronto
donc on peut prétendre qu'on a une
baisse s'était autres canadiennes qui
est inscrite à la bourse de toronto
mais dans les faits la véritable
question qu'on doit se poser
où sont les véritables décisions sont
prises
pourquoi le yuko alors grâce au prize
peppers
nous avons accès à des procès verbaux du
conseil d'administration de katanga
mining qui nous en apprennent un peu
plus sur ce choix qui peut surprendre
on comprend qu'on n'a pas besoin d'avoir
des administrateurs qui sont résidents
canadiens pour pouvoir affirmer conseil
incorporé au yukon kinshasa est en cours
l'adresse de whitehorse et celle d'un
bureau d'avocats ce n'est pas tout la
compagnie de hugh quand on n'exploite
pas directement sa mine au congo elle le
fait à travers plusieurs autres entités
dans des pays connus comme des paradis
fiscaux les îles vierges britanniques
par exemple et lille demain on voit que
toutes les activités réelles que génère
des profits sont en afrique
mais toutes les sociétés qui détiennent
des parts dans ces sociétés ce soit en
afrique sont dans les paradis fiscaux
oui je voulais juste de parler
d'entrevue qu'on a fait la semaine deux
avec édouard perrin et nos autres
collègues de la csg en fouillant dans la
structure des actionnaires de katanga
mining
nous avons constaté que glencore à
brasser des affaires dans ce projet avec
un individu au passé trouble presqu'à
chaque deal que les différents
entreprises sont en train de faire dans
le domaine minière au congo
presque tous batum est presque tous
s'impliquent d'un goal
dan carter est un israélien qui fait des
affaires en afrique depuis plus d'une
quinzaine d'années à travers ses
sociétés privées son nom apparaît depuis
longtemps dans les enquêtes des ong des
quelqu'un qui est assez proche président
joseph kabila quelqu'un qui a beaucoup
gagné du congo en 2001 un rapport
d'experts du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu décrit comment une entreprise de
dan gertler s'était entendu avec le
président laurent désiré kabila pour
payer 20 millions de dollars en échange
d'un monopole de vente de diamants
estimés à 600 millions $ par an le
contrat contenaient des clauses secrètes
qui prévoyait aussi la livraison d'armes
et d'instructeurs grâce aux contacts de
dan carter avec des militaires
israéliens
et après ça qu'il a élargi les domaines
sur laquelle est un tracé au congo mais
ça a commencé avec les diamants par la
voix de ses avocats ding denis toutes
les allégations du rapport de l'onu mais
au fil des ans des rapports de plusieurs
ong remettent en question ses
transactions en territoire congolais et
plusieurs questions qu'on se pose et a
eu des rapports aussi sérieux c'est
clairement un immense drapeau rouge
qu'un dû être soulevée pour la compagnie
glencore lewenza
global witness alerté glencore très tôt
sur le risque de faire affaire avec dan
carter on a commencé à créer un clan qu
en 2012
au début ils ont dit nos toutous
tu n'oses accord avec dingue adler sont
il n'y a pas de problème il n'y a pas de
débat des questions de corruption et ses
trains ils ont été satisfaits des dit
que d'un gars tu laisses c'est notre
partenaire en business au congo pendant
des années les liens entre glencore est
un vecteur dépasse le simple fait qu'il
soit actionnaire dans katanga mining à
la bourse de toronto en 2009 plein qu'on
a prêté 45 millions de dollars à une
société associé à dan carter laura
enterprises ce qui permettra à
d'ailleurs d'acquérir plus d'action dans
katanga mining quand la personne en
question est une grande amie du
président congolais qui va avoir une
grande influence sur les attributions
milliers à sa s'élève à encore plus de
questions
les penguins peuvent nous révèle que
dans l'ouverture soit à l'heure de
glencore le mandat de négocier au nom de
katanga mining avec les représentants de
l'état congolais
moi ma lecture est assez simple on lui
prête 45 millions on lui donne trois
mois pour aller chercher un contrat avec
le gouvernement
global witness a senti le besoin
d'alerter les autorités canadiennes
en 2012 nous avons écrit à la commission
des valeurs mobilières de l'ontario pour
des cons avait des inquiétudes autour
des deals d'glingue cours avec les
sociétés offshore tout un gode la gêne
aux caisses que glencore et dan gertler
ont à dire au sujet du prêt de 45
millions alors tant glencore que les
avocats de dans leur coeur nous rappelle
que ce prêt a été conclu pour des
raisons purement commerciales est tout à
fait légitime et d'ailleurs que le prêt
a été remboursé intégralement l'année
suivante quand même gino c'est pas le
seul nuage qui plane sur les activités
de glencore au canada non et au retour
on vous raconte l'histoire de
travailleurs québécois qui ce but
présentement à l'ancienne quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bastien robin ds4
qassem atta
juin dernier huit heures du matin les
travailleurs de cuisine c'est au zinc à
salaberry de valleyfield ralentissent
l'entrée des véhicules
ils veulent s'assurer qu'aucun briseurs
de grève ne franchissent les portes on
les connaît légaux pour la plupart
ce qui s'en vient de faire la mécanique
glace ou de la tuyauterie d'électricité
des inspecteurs gouvernementaux ont
constaté la présence de briseurs de
grève il ya quelques semaines
l'employeur dit que c'est faux et s'en
défend devant les tribunaux la grève de
ses trois cent soixante et onze
travailleurs a commencé en février
glencore est un des actionnaires de
l'entreprise et il est le gestionnaire
des opérations et glencore a émis sa
compagnie et nous fournissent le minerai
déjà les employés finale à qui ça
profite à conflit là tous nos
indications nous prendre en compte la
direction de cae zinc veut réduire ses
dépenses et demande des concessions aux
employés de l'usiné est donc essentiel
d'assurer la viabilité d'un outil zen
que nous réduisons nos coûts de façon
permanente dans son cadre financier
luigi foschi qu ils n'agissent jamais
prouvé ou montrer qui est en difficulté
financière
même si les activités de la cia zinc et
de glencore font l'objet de divulgation
publique en bourse il ya une limite à ce
qui est public pour une multinationale
comme glencore avec des structures
comportant des dizaines et des dizaines
de sociétés voir la rentabilité d'une
des filiales devient complexe mais
généralement plus vous en avez plus ça
devient difficile aussi pour des
personnes sont à l'extérieur de vérifier
de suivre toute la trace de l'argent
et des filiales glencore on a une
multitude aussi dans les paradis fiscaux
en fouillant dans les paradise papers
les journalistes de la cie ag ont
documenté que seulement aux bermudes
la compagnie on a des tenues plus de
soixante dix au fil des ans
glencore assure que la plupart des
entités qu'elle détenait encore là-bas
paye depuis récemment leurs impôts en
europe
martin kind avocat et dans le ring au
mois de mai dernier
des syndiqués de glencore des quatre
coins du monde se sont donné rendez vous
au siège mondial de l'entreprise en
suisse nous sommes à quelques heures
l'assemblée annuelle de la compagnie
poser des questions parmi eux se
trouvent les représentants du syndicat
de lysine de valleyfield qui se joint au
groupe
venu manifester lors de l'assemblée de
l'unsco
pendant ce temps notre collègue français
édouard perrin se prépare lui aussi à
l'assemblée de glencore en compagnie des
journalistes
oliver hillman de suisse et catherine
mangane d'allemagne lui aussi espère
pouvoir poser des questions à la
direction de l'entreprise sur ses liens
avec l'homme d'affaires dan carter en
république démocratique du congo
surtout qu'entre temps une nouvelle
tuile s'est abattue sur dan carter en
septembre 2016 un autre partenaire
d'affaires de daggerfall en afrique
la firme américaine actifs reconnaît sa
participation dans une stratagème de
corruption et de fait contre céphalées
états unis était explosif et quelque
chose très important pour la première
fois découvrir la réalité de qu'est-ce
qui se passe d'ondés différentes d'il au
combo
auxi acceptent de payer plus de 400
millions de dollars d'amendé dans le
cadre de règlement judiciaire
les documents du règlement pointent en
direction de dan gertler sans le nommer
on allègue qu'il aurait versé des
dizaines de millions de dollars en
pots-de-vin à des dirigeants congolais
pour nous c'est un justification de ce
qu'on a dit pendant des années depuis
2006 c'était que ces entreprises ils ont
choisi d'un gala comme partenaire à
cause de ses relations avec le pouvoir
au congo les enquêteurs américains
identifie tout de même une des sociétés
de dan carter laura enterprises lorraine
jeu pareil c'était juste une façon de
faciliter cette corruption pour payer
les différents genres l'argent pour
assurer que les mines se trouve chez
danker et les entreprises qu'elles
contrôlent entreprises c'est aussi cette
même compagnie qui est relié à katanga
mining à la bourse de toronto
l'organisme wade demande une enquête aux
autorités canadiennes
je pense est possible que le tueur en
stock exchange gets tsx était utilisé
pour faciliter la corruption
dan carter toujours par l'entremise de
ses avocats rejette l'énoncé de faits le
concernant
contenu dans le règlement judiciaire aux
etats-unis il ajoute qu'il n'était pas
parti et ce règlement et il n'a pas été
interrogé par les enquêteurs américains
glencore a depuis racheté toutes les
actions détenues par des entités relié à
dan gertler dans katanga mining
comment se fait-il qu'on rachète
dépendre de quelqu'un qui peut faire
face à des accusations criminelles et
qu'on rachète ses parts à lui ni lui ni
ses compagnies ne font l'objet d'aucune
accusation dans ce dossier d'ailleurs
dans gurtler assure respecter toutes les
lois
partout où il a des activités 24 mai
si le jour de l'assemblée annuelle de
glencore en suisse à l'extérieur les
syndiqués de valleyfield sont avec leurs
confrères pour se faire entendre avant
l'assemblée à l'intérieur edouard perrin
à l'occasion de questionner la direction
de lenco mike white une escouade symbo
dit
glencore oryx d'idriss events in the
contract in which involve personnes
comment l'expression encore aujourd'hui
glencore conserve des liens avec des
ouvertures sa filiale katanga mining
payent des redevances minières non pas à
une société d'état congolaise comme
habituellement
mais à une compagnie de dan carter
selon glencore cet arrangement a été
fait à la demande les autorités
congolaises selon un article du wall
street journal les autorités canadiennes
mènerait enquête à ce sujet ni le tsx ni
la commission des valeurs mobilières de
l'ontario n'ont voulu confirmer quelque
enquête que ce soit il reste aucun doute
caire
il ya des gens qui doit faire une
enquêtrice au canada pour vérifier qu
est-ce que glencore a fait à cette
époque qu'est ce qu'un clank un arrêt du
fin pendant que plusieurs questions
demeurent
anna quai van woudenberg a une pensée
pour le peuple congolais qu'elle côtoie
encore régulièrement lors de ses séjours
en rdc
j'ai vu la pauvreté j'ai vu les
souffrances des gens on a en fait une
situation où le peuple contraire gagne
très peu de cette ressource naturelle
qui peut vraiment développer ce pays et
je trouve ça très triste
[Musique]
genou après votre reportage sur glane
quand on se demande où en est le conflit
l usine c est dingue de
salaberry-de-valleyfield
alors la semaine dernière les deux
parties ont demandé la nomination d'un
médiateur spécial par le gouvernement du
québec
ce qui est certain c'est qu'avec 13
millions de documents dans les périodes
les spurs ya encore beaucoup de travail
pour les journalistes l'équipe d'
enquête va continuer à fouiller ça va
alimenter nos prochains reportage au nom
de toute l'équipe je vous remercie
d'avoir été là on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour une autre enquête
[Musique]